[Music]
[Applause]
uh Michael Porter Jr now of the NBA
champion Denver Nuggets joining us on
the program
how was the party is it still going on
yeah it's still going on
um it'll probably be going on for
another two weeks so we're still
enjoying enjoying it okay when Joker
says he's not sure about this parade and
he finds out it's Thursday and then he's
like he doesn't want to go to the parade
he wants to go home is is he being
serious
probably I think he wants to get home to
his horses he wants to get home you know
to his people back in Serbia but he'll
be there and then he'll probably leave
the day after so well this is what I'm
thinking Mike I think we let him have
his Victory Parade in Serbia
so you simulcast it with your parade in
Denver let him be on his horse let him
uh put him on the Jumbotron let him have
his brothers there the entire city where
he's from and then you can have two
different parties everybody wins we keep
we keep uh joke uh Joker happy
now he's got to celebrate here with us
uh I mean as much as he wants to get
home to Serbia
I mean we got to celebrate with the fans
we we saw the videos of them going crazy
in the city during the game you know
what I mean so we gotta we gotta turn up
with the fans
take me back to fourth quarter late in
the game and I think Miami's up by one
you guys have a timeout and Jokers
Jokers yelling like he's mad
do you remember what was being said in
the Huddle at that time
I forget what he was saying I think he
was just you know trying to get
everybody to realize which we did you
know
the right now it's it's do or die like
we we can we can win this game two
minutes left it's anybody's ball game
just have to lock in have to get a good
shot up every time on the floor and then
have to play defense and rebound at what
point in the season did it click where
you go
we're the best team in basketball
yeah I um man it's it's just it's really
crazy because there's so many good teams
in the NBA any given night you can you
can lose to any team it doesn't matter
if they're the number one seed or the
last seed
um so we knew we were pretty good all
season but I think the last month of the
Season we kind of had some slippers we
were losing teams we shouldn't have lost
to you know wondering like okay
are we as good as we think we are you
know what I mean so going into the
playoffs I think it was just a A Renewed
Focus I feel like losing a couple of
those games late in the season kind of
renewed our Focus going to play I Was
realizing we could be beat if we don't
if we don't bring it you know what I
mean so
um that's kind of uh helped us focus a
little bit more into going to the
playoffs and we just we felt good about
ourselves what's it like though growing
up I think you were the high school
player of the year in 2017 and then here
you are playing against LeBron and then
Kevin Durant the playoffs you might have
had their posters on your wall growing
up what what's that like though when
you're going against these guys who are
you know future Hall of Famers
yeah I think first of all it's a
testament to their greatness you know
what I mean that it at this time they're
still as great as they are when I grew
up watching them when I was a kid so it
shows those guys longevity
um but no it is it is a surreal feeling
to be able to knock those guys out of
the playoffs you know along our way to
the championship like we we beat some
really good players some really good
teams on our way to winning this
Championship so
um
it's amazing I think uh
like growing up like you said you watch
those guys you watch them in the finals
and then to be there to do that it it
really is pretty surreal if I would have
told you after you had your first back
surgery
when you were at Missouri hey you're
going to win a championship one day in
the NBA
what would you have said
that's my first one I would have
believed you I would I would have
believed I would have got there what
about after your third one
yeah after the third one I I would have
hoped I didn't know for sure I was gonna
keep going I was going to keep you know
attacking my rehab hoping I made it back
to where where I was but I didn't know
so to actually to do it you know what
did we would do one year after
um you know having having my third back
surgery it's I can't it's it's it's
really amazing and then you got Jamal
Murray with Jamal's you know when he
blew out his ACL to be able to come back
I think that's probably why he was so
emotional after uh the win because he
had as a long road back for him
yeah I just think um you know
for me as well when you when you have
the amazing moments like winning a
championship like the first thing you
kind of do is just reflect on all the
time to get there and uh for me and
Jamal specifically like not too long ago
we were in the training room now
wondering if we'd be the same players
and I'm wondering if we'd be able to
help his team
um knowing it was in us but not knowing
if we'd be able to go do it again so
um I think that's probably what he was
reflecting on you know that's what I was
reflecting on just how much sacrifice it
took to get here but how worth it it is
we're talking to Michael Porter Jr
Denver Nuggets forward how Unstoppable
is Joker
yeah I think everyone kind of saw this
playoffs you you can't really uh
I was actually asking our offensive
coach uh the other day I was like okay
Coach how would you how would you how
would you guard a what do you think how
would you guard our team would you
double a joke in the post would you play
them straight up and and let him score
40 I was doubling trying to get the ball
out of his hands and there's really no
real answer because as good of a score
he is he's just as good of a passer you
know what I mean just as good of the
password he's just this is a rebounder
so when other guys are shooting he's
getting offensive rebounds so
he does it in so many different ways you
know it doesn't matter what teams throw
it at us he figures it out we figured
out as a team and and give the credit
heat like uh I give the heat credit we
we scored under 100 points that last
game in the series and we were like low
scoring all series they played great
defense you know what I mean
um and that's really what we're
championships are won like they say
um you win championships through defense
and we kind of saw that uh I had uh Rex
Chapman former NBA player on yesterday I
said who does uh jokic remind you of and
he said he's a seven foot Steve Nash
yeah that's a good company that's
amazing though right like past first and
not many guys who averaged 28 29 30 are
a past first Superstar yeah no that's
that's what makes him so unique because
he really can go out there and probably
score 40 points a game like if we were
to give it to another post and just say
like go score every time he scored 40 a
game but uh to get the assist to be a
pass first player
that's a good comparison I like the
comparison
um you know this year another guy that
reminds people of Joker is Luca but
Lucas you know a guard Joker's a big man
who's who's still doing all the same
things pushing up the floor shooting
threes uh mid-range floaters but passing
it as well and it's a little different
coming from a big man because
like a point guard like Steve Nash he's
making passes
you know at the top of the floor like
he's Diamond people whatever Joker it's
it's different because you don't see big
men who are passing out of the post like
that you know uh passing it to Cutters
when they double team so he's a really
unique player I don't think people
um really congrats how unique of a
player he is well you gotta always keep
your head up because if not you're going
to get hit in the side of the head with
a pass from him right yeah nah for sure
and we uh you know dating all the way
back to training camp
we we just have figured out a system how
to play with them I think when we traded
for Aaron Gordon it really helped our
team he's great off the ball obviously
very athletic so it opened up a lot for
our team when Aaron came but yeah you
definitely got to keep your head up
did you keep your uniform
I actually gave my final that last game
uniform to my family but I have all the
rest of the playoff jerseys so I'm gonna
end up sending sending them out to
different people
all right well just make sure you don't
lose that because you know sometimes
those things get lost and who's got the
basketball who's from the uh
from the game
you know what I think uh
because I heard him saying in the in the
Lakers series one of our one of our uh
Player Development coaches he tried to
get the ball after we won the Lakers
series yeah
um so he probably went and he said as
soon as the buzzer was going off he was
going to get the ball before the rest he
probably got it good it's gonna be worth
some money
enjoy the parade
thank you man I appreciate you all right
that's uh Michael Porter Jr uh nuggets
forward he had uh 16 points 13 rebounds
in that game five win
uh it should be fun tomorrow I you know
all I want to see is Joker I just want
to see if he's enjoying himself